foreign
she has told me
um just recently that when she was 15
she had consensual sex with a 22 year
old and all my notes I have consensual
in quotes yes she did not she was raped
by an adult
[Music]
yo-yos daloney with a Dr John deloney's
show
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting and whatever else is going on
in your life podcast ever
we're real people calling with real
challenges and here's my promise I'm not
gonna lie to you and I'm gonna sit down
next to you blow up a seat and we will
figure out what's the next right best
thing to do and I'm so grateful that you
people calling in hey your letters dude
I'm so grateful for your letters um I'll
get to I got a big chunk of them over
the holidays I'm gonna get to those soon
and I'm so grateful for you who have
chosen to spend your most precious
resource your time with us I'm just so
honored to end and uh blessed I
appreciate it um hey it was my birthday
recently uh I turned 22 and Kelly
got me the metal uh Legends alphabet
book Incredible
let's just play a little bit
um let's see here pick a letter then
I'm gonna go Q
ooh Queen's Right Jet City whoa like
this is like uh this whole book is just
like my childhood CD case exciting and
it took me down a type of negative
rabbit hole which is a slow sludgy
rabbit hole with vampires very cool all
right let's go to Brittany and
shy Town Chicago what's up Brittany
hi Dr John how are you good awesome
what's up
um I am wondering how to grieve the
picture I had of a family for my son
that's a hard one that's a big one man
what's so tell me more
okay
um I have a nine month old son
and his dad and I were back and forth we
haven't been together since the
pregnancy and stuff but we are back and
forth and we've been back and forth
since he's been born and recently he's
kind of drawn the line saying it's not
going to work out we're not going to be
together
and my head knows it for the best but my
heart doesn't like that and because I've
always wanted a family dynamic because I
came from a divorced home so I didn't
really want that for my kids
um and I know that we're toxic together
we just we've tried and tried and just
doesn't work but I want to be able to
co-parent without wanting the Romantic
part with him
uh okay so I was gonna ask when you guys
were back on and back off
was it physical I mean was it mostly
jailers hooking up and that you
were doing your best to woo him and win
him back and he was just you know
getting to hook up on the side and you
you had more invested than he did or had
y'all sat down and said let's try to
give us a run
um we've we did kind of both
um throughout the time we've been we've
it's been I think four years this year
so we were together for two straight and
then it was just kind of back and forth
and when he found out you were pregnant
you all broke up
um no we weren't together then
um we actually hooked up and that's how
okay so
um yeah
um
what does this guy bring you so let's
take your let's take your family picture
aside let's what does this guy bring you
he's obviously a great lover like you
keep going back you keep going back even
though you know it it it digs your hole
a little bit deeper right and it makes
you feel worse every time but you keep
going back what is it about him
um honestly I feel like it's kind of all
like he wanted me and I wanted him and I
feel like kind of feel like that's all
I'm gonna ever get in life I guess
say more about that
like I don't know an acetylene
um mindset I guess
um
[Music]
well I got cheated on before him we were
I was married for about four years and
he cheated on me oh man okay
so you've had a series of all the way
back from when you were a kid of core
relationships falling apart in front of
you
and as a kid you feel really powerless
when Mom and Dad decide
they're going separate ways and married
to somebody that you love and you had
said I'm all in on you feel very
powerless too
him saying hey I chose somebody else and
then yet again right yeah I'm sorry
how old are you
uh 28 28.
so you're old enough to have a bunch of
scars relational scars and you're young
enough
that you still got your whole life ahead
of you yeah
called your little boy
uh he's nine months nine months yeah
tell me about him
oh he's great
um I don't know his babies literacy is
super easy to take care of he's just a
really easy kid good sleeper he loves
his food
so you you have created a picture in
your head this is how I wanted this to
go
the challenge with the picture you
created was
um and this isn't a knock this is just
me sitting by you and we're just owning
reality together okay
um you didn't have the skills and you
didn't have the partner to make that
picture a reality
so it became more of a wish than a
something I'm headed towards does that
make sense yeah and so
right now you're it's it's just entering
into a season of grief and it's a both
and I'm grieving I wanted this thing
and it's not here
and so
um I'm gonna continue to say it out loud
you asked how I grieved this season you
say it out loud like what you just said
like you have a group of core people
that you could speak in and say I'm sad
today
and they say man we're sitting here with
you and
we're sad with you and at the same time
you begin learning new skills learning
to make meaning of this and head into
another Direction because if you don't
heal you're going to find yourself with
another guy that says yeah I want you
or at least want what you can do for me
and that will be enough for yet another
season
right
yeah and you'll continue in that cycle
over and over and over again
why'd your parents get divorced
um I think it just didn't work out I I
really don't know I was two so I don't
really remember much
did you have relationship with both your
parents
um I didn't talk to my dad from my
eighth grade year until I graduated high
school how come
um alcohol
okay
so you had divorce on top of an addict
yeah
have you ever sat down and talked to
somebody
okay how's that been going not well
um it's it's good
it's not really
why isn't it good
um I mean I think I'm I think I'm
learning a lot and growing and stuff I
just it's the relationship parts that
get me okay so what I would tell you is
um if you're I can't tell you what to do
I'm just telling you if you were my
sister or you were my best buddy here's
what I would tell you okay
it will probably be a long while before
you don't like remember how great it was
sleeping with this guy
or in the moments that were really good
how deeply connected and loved he made
you feel
it's gonna be a long time till you don't
quote unquote feel that
and maybe you get married again have a
great husband and you show up to high
school graduation with your little boy
and his dad is there with his new wife
and you see him hug your son who's now
18 after he walks across the stage and
your heart skips a beat a little bit
all right so there's that feeling and
I'll tell anybody all day like the
feelings are fine that's okay that's
life
it's what are you going to do with that
feeling and so you can have the feeling
I still want to be with him or when I'm
going to drop off my son if he says hey
you want to come in you know what that
means
and you feel like yes but I'm not gonna
do that because now I'm healing and I'm
moving on with my life
and there's that gap between what I feel
like I want to do and what I know is the
right next move for me
and what you I wish I had a a more
clinical word than this but you got to
practice you just got to decide I'm
going to move into this area I'm gonna
practice
and it's going to feel lonely and it's
going to feel like you just you going to
work and then coming home and talking to
a blah blah blah and changing lots of
diapers and then repeat
um
and that's going to be why you have to
get other people in your life a couple
of friends that you can meet with and
that will be connected to you that's why
you have to have a counselor you've got
a history
of a little girl wondering why everybody
keeps leaving her
is that fair yeah very sure
foreign
we have to say they people did leave
and we're going to learn the new skills
moving forward so that we're not trying
to continually date and marry our
unfinished business but we're going to
create that picture that we've got in
our heart and mind
[Music]
that makes sense yeah
it's okay to be really really sad I'm
sorry
what's your next move
I don't know
are you sad about him are you sad about
that you found Yourself by yourself
or the exact thing that you didn't want
to have happen has happened
um I think I'm sad that
that currently on loan lonely I guess
but I want what's best for my son
well what's best for
your son is that Mom is whole and what's
best for your son is that mom's got some
friends she can laugh with and play with
and bring over and maybe they can bring
up their little knucklehead kids and
then all of our kids can make big
knuckleheaded kid piles on the floor
right yeah
um
I say this with all love and due respect
loneliness at some point becomes a
choice it becomes a decision to that
that's I'm gonna sit in this I'm gonna
baste in this or
I'm gonna Brave the Wilderness I'm going
back out and I might get
somebody might cheat on me again someone
might break up with me again and I'm not
suggesting you run out and start dating
again that may not be the right move
right now but I am suggesting
I'm gonna call some friends from work
and they're just gonna invite them over
we're gonna hang out I'm going to and
they can't stay very late because I got
a little boy and we gotta get him in the
bath we gotta get him to bed or maybe
they can stay late because we're gonna
get him to bed and then after that or
maybe I'm gonna pass him around and he's
going to get all kinds of love from two
or three other unstressed Out friends
um
you
that means you're gonna have to reach
again
and the last thing your body wants you
to do is to go be vulnerable again go
say hey will you be my friend again
because you got burned and you got
burned you got burned you got burned
what I'll tell you is
the only way to peace was having people
in your life
and my sister you gotta get the healing
that you need at some point you gotta
let that little girl off the hook cause
she's still playing defense for it you
gotta let her go play
I'll let that little girl go play
your mom and dad broke it up
dad got stuck in a bottle
first husband cheated on you
second hot second boyfriend baby daddy
said I'm out
it's a lonely dark place
the light here is you
doing the next right thing we'll be
right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we're back during the break I
uh I should have said this earlier I
sent her a copy of on your past change
of features to book to sit down with and
say okay this stuff happened to me it
keeps happening to me now what right now
what comes next
um and sometimes I'll tell you these
calls those calls are hard because
um
she's got a body that is constantly
trying to protect her from relationships
because relationships have caused so
much damage and so in a nine minute
phone call and a 10 minute call it's
um
it's disrespectful for me it's it's uh
grandiose to think I can I can sit down
and say the five or six magic words to
help somebody and make it all right I
can't
um somebody in her situation is gonna
need some long-term therapy You're Gonna
Learn long-term care do some hard work
day by day by day what I can offer in 10
minutes is you're not crazy and I'm
sorry with you
and you're on the right path you got to
get some professional help to walk
alongside you because you had a a whole
lot of mess and Trauma in your life it's
just a mess man
um I want to thank her so so much for
calling let's go to Sarah and Joshua
Texas what's up Sarah
hi Dr John deloney what a pleasure what
a pleasure it is Sarah my favorite
podcast and also mortifying it's all
good what's up
uh so I since I was six years old I have
what I didn't know was a disorder until
I was 15. uh a skin picking Disorder so
my my fingertips
are just always kind of cut and bloody
and then it you know when I was 15 I
started pulling my hair out and there's
names for these things
oh my gosh you know the name hey uh do
you okay we're gonna we're already here
so we're gonna keep going do you
um
when you pull out like eyelashes or hair
do you eat it
no I don't and I have heard of that but
no that's not me okay all right all
right
um
wow so why six
that is just a memory that's me
remembering the first time I was ever
bothering with my hands and I remember
being scolded for it to my my dad he he
would always tell me you know quit doing
that that's a habit
it's not a habit it is a
compulsion that's very very different
and people people don't understand that
they think it's just something that you
do because you do it it's it no it is
it's very purposeful it's not mindless
and it's excruciating it's it's
exhausting yes and you know I'm 31 now
it's been my whole life yes
um
how would you define a compulsion
when you
cannot refrain
okay
does that make sense yes I am so strange
it's strange because I am a very
controlled person I don't have
I don't have any vices I don't have
addictions I've never gotten caught up
with things that all of my friends did
you know I never got caught up in
alcohol cigarettes drugs like nothing
literally nothing maybe if you'd had a
few drinks I'm just kidding
um so that actually doesn't surprise me
at all
okay the
so do you promise that that you like
that you know I'm not I'm I'm uh I'm on
your side
I can believe that okay okay
um okay so let's do this first so you
can take
uh we'll geek out for just eight seconds
you can take like a past digging
approach like a psycho and a little a
psychoanalytic approach like what
happened in your past what what things
are being repressed what things happened
that led to this Behavior you can do
that and you can also take a very strict
behavioral approach okay
um that this is this is
um it's it's a it's a it's a learned
habit just a habit and then it just
ingrained itself and the Habit
ultimately becomes a compulsion
there's been some recent studies
um
that suggest that it could also be very
biological in nature
like this is a brain
on a loop trying to solve some things
for itself or there's a serotonogenic
issues or there's all kinds of of
neurotransmitter neuromodulator issues
here's what I'm telling you that
I don't want you spending so much energy
a asking what's wrong with you
why are you broken
two you've probably spent a fair amount
of time
playing Indiana Jones with your past
trying to figure this out is that fair
um I wrote it down last week
literally trying to find a trigger or a
pattern or something
I'm and what you said you said Loop I'm
a
I wouldn't say that I'm a a person of
high anxiety but I'm very cyclic I
I will just run around in circles in my
brain until I find correct the word of
the issue and I don't know I don't know
maybe that does Define me as high
anxiety but I don't I don't know I was
recently having a conversation with a
good buddy of mine is a psychologist at
Brown University uh at the in the in the
research hospital
and I have a theory that I'm just
working through and I asked him like I
was like hey I need to talk through this
with you because as I read more nerd
literature
um the scientific studies
I I'm coming to believe and I have
nothing to back this up okay so this is
me just spitballing with my buddy uh but
he did say man I think you are dead on
to something and in fact he told me a
bunch of other studies I didn't know
existed
um some out of Kansas some out of a
couple other places that um would would
suggest that
I the way we are trained is that OCD
that basically life happens to you and
based off of your genetics some people
get dragged down into depression other
people get spun up into anxiety but that
it's a body reacting to stimulus it it
can't it's exceeding its capacity to to
deal with it and a derivative of anxiety
is OCD
I have been really
um
Blown Away by some of the the
neuroimaging around OCD
to the point that I am beginning to
wonder and Alan short did some great
work here
I think the root is OCD and depression
and anxiety and all of these other
Downstream things that we try to do
is our bodies trying to stop the loop
and you are a person of high control
who has been told since you were a
little girl that the way you control
things is gross and disgusting quit and
they may have loved you and been
incredible and wonderful
but sometimes depending on what kind of
brain you were born with and genetics
you were born with and experiences you
had
it may just take a splinter a crack in
the way you respond is wrong and who you
are is wrong
and your body says we've got to solve
for that and it gets anxious about it
and then it becomes a loop that gets
etched into concrete so I would my
challenge to you is a compulsion is a
habit on steroids
I think trying to differentiate between
the two of them uh is uh is a waste of
time and energy
your body has tried to figure out a way
to make you feel better and this is the
way it's chosen
do you wish it was something else for
sure
um but this is what you got and so
here's why I tell you all it's not
visible or obvious like something I can
hide I can't I can't I can't hide this
that's right that's right but here's the
thing
you can't hate your body into healing
and you have been at war with Sarah
since you were six years old right
yes absolutely you've got to make peace
with Sarah
and the moment you can and literally
it's a moment the moment you can begin
to I mean you've probably heard of uh
ACT therapy act like acceptance and
commitment
you have to switch from war to curiosity
that's your only path forward
because every time you pull your hair
out you get pissed and you think you
screwed up something or you think what
are you doing why are you doing oh my
gosh
it's the worst it's the worst and people
who struggle with binge eating people
who struggle I mean it's these
compulsions people who smoke who grab
cigarettes who just sit in their
bathroom and have imaginary wars with
other people and it's like I can't stop
fighting somebody in my head and then I
see them at work and my body's like
there they are kill them and they're so
kind they're offering me a drink right
like it's like it's these habits these
Loops that become compulsions that we
lose control of
and the key back to control is curiosity
huh
what's my body trying to protect me from
and I'm saying it with a smile on my
face
what is my body trying to solve right
now
because it is pulling hair out of itself
and I'm also you see I'm I'm putting
some gaps between you
and what's happening
you are not your trick to a Mania you're
not a lunatic you're not crazy you're
not disgusting you're not gross
your body's figured out a way to solve a
thing
and it's just the solution isn't very
helpful
or actually I would bet you it's really
really really helpful or it wouldn't
keep doing it
but it's helpful that also doesn't make
sense it doesn't help
it makes me feel worse
but does it shift your focus away from
what you can't control
oh absolutely does it shift your focus
away from the battles that are you are
raging on a daily basis that you can't
fix or change
well sometimes it's just I'm just trying
to work like I can't even be at work I
you know I work I work at a desk and I
actually work remote at work at home so
I'm just trying to be productive and
it's the only way I can describe it is
like someone's tapping on the back of
your head oh yeah and you and you are
you know plotting the weight and you try
to make it stop and they
still chopping on the back of your head
until you give your attention to that
and then the whole day goes by I haven't
been as productive as I want to and
that's only one example I have children
like sometimes I can't be present in
anywhere else in my life because my
fingertips are bothering me that's so
absurd my eyelashes are bothering me who
feels their eyelashes like I'm not even
supposed to notice those things
says who
oh I I guess just general sane people
you've constructed a whole planet
about how terrible Sarah is and she's
not she's not
she's not
I will admit the things that you
struggle with are hard because they're
they're they are outside the norm they
don't happen to a lot of people although
I think the number I saw was 10 million
or 8 million people I mean so it's not
an insignificant number of people who
struggle with this
but it is weird if you're sitting there
and you're
picking at your finger until it's
bleeding and you're pulling a piece of
hair out the back of your head and
you're doing it mindlessly while you're
watching TV and you look over and your
little son is our daughter staring at
you like what is that yeah that's
unnerving that's weird right it is
but you have create a constructed a
character around this of a lunatic unfit
to be a parent shouldn't be even in an
office with people
and you've created a whole person and
you hate that person
foreign
[Music]
I see that
let's try this
and at the root of that I think this is
and again some of the neurological stuff
can be grooming habits that are wired
into us
that are just a little bit off the rails
okay and so it might be something as
simple as man I I need to take an SSRI
and have you tried that before
no I'm I'm actually not even familiar I
I
um I went to a therapist one time when I
was 15. I was prescribed antidepressants
tried that for about a week then I
refused them and never went back to a
professional ever again there is some um
there is some evidence to suggests
um ssris it's it's not
um benzodiazepines but it's it's ssris
that help with anxiety they're
anti-anxiety things but what here's what
here's the way I characterize them they
just turn the alarms down
so that I can go do the work that I
gotta do
so for instance when I was sorry go
ahead buried in anxiety I was sat at my
table I met with my buddy who's a
medical doctor again I'm super
privileged to have a close friend who I
love and Trust that's a medical doctor I
get that but um I sat with him for a
long time and he said hey man I don't
see a path out of this for you without
some really good counseling and some
behavior modification and you can't
you're not in a place to do that
I sat at my table with a low level SSRI
that I cut in half okay so the lowest
dose and I cut that in half
and I wept because I thought I was a
failure
I thought I was a total loser
I had a new baby my son was like one
years old and I thought I was a such a
failure
and I wouldn't put a pill in my mouth
until I had a plan off of it my doctor
was like super helpful in making that
plan that plan was not even close to
reality but he humored me on it and um
here's all it did it did not solve my
anxiety it didn't solve my control
issues it didn't solve my loneliness it
didn't solve all these things
it didn't make me less addiction prone
it didn't make any of that stuff go away
what it did was it turned the Alarm
Systems way down
so that when I felt a compulsion to do
something I could
be curious about it
that tapping you feel it would make it
more like a like a like a whisper or a
breath instead of a A bamming in the
back of your head this is just me this
is me hypothesis like I'm just I'm not
saying you need to go get meds I'm
saying here's what it did for me and
what I want what I'm trying to get you
to do is to open up it may be time to
sit down and say okay what I've done to
this far it hasn't worked cool my body's
still getting what it needs from me by
doing this
um I want to stop this Behavior so let's
try another Avenue that may be
medication that may be hypnosis that may
mean be EMDR that may be several other
avenues but let's give this a shot does
that make sense
yes what I don't want you to do is to
give in to Despair and quit and think
you're screwed up and broken
because here's why you start to turn
from your kids
Fair
yeah and you create space between your
kids are you married
no
okay
you create space between romantic
partners and they think it's their fault
is that fair
foreign
I get that I get that
I'm afraid if I
if I take something that numbs the
alarms what else is it going to numb it
says that's absolutely Fair
and there's certain drugs that um I
wouldn't I have written into my
um
psychiatric power of attorney that I
won't have in my body because they turn
joy and paying off at the same switch
right and so that's terrifying yeah it
is it is and also
um
I can just tell you my experience
um I am somebody who does not advocate
for medication and it was a powerful
um tool in my tool kit when I was
getting well
and I haven't been on it in years years
and years and years
but for a season man it was powerful
and again that might not be your journey
what you need to do is figure out ways
you can make peace with Sarah because
you can't Over Control Sarah because
this whole thing is a control response
or maybe a biological thing which then
you're going to need medication and so
you have a heart like and just be
grateful that you live in this one with
a weird sliver of time and we have all
of this you know incredible technology
all right
but all of this here's all this is
making peace with Sarah
will you do me just of all the favors
I'm asking one I think you should go
talk to somebody not because you're
broken but but because like you have
tried to fix the plumbing under your
house
and you're like I don't know how to do
what's next that's it you just had a
professional is gonna have different
skills you're not screwed up you're not
broken you're not ah you just don't have
the skill set there that's great that's
awesome you have tried and you'd be like
all right I need someone with different
skills luckily there's people who went
to college for a long time to learn how
those skills that can help okay
that's number one
underneath that number two is
I want you to keep a journal
and I want you to begin to write five
things a day
that you are that you love about Sarah
okay you actually never Journal
I I could have I would have bet my car
on that my car is not nice that would
have been a great big bet but
um you you strike me as such a loving
caring person and
that love and care is wrapped over like
like
um wrapping paper over
a nuclear
bombs worth of energy
grasping for control
and at some point we have to release the
tension that is held underneath that
thing and for most people in that
situation
that feels like the end of their life
because if I let this thing unwind this
thing I'm controlling and compressing
and holding on to it all of my mind if I
let it go everything spins into chaos in
the most terrifying thing is chaos
and so when I start to feel chaos and I
start to feel something I can't control
like my kids Behavior like my husband
walking out on me like climate change
like whatever else you think is coming
the economy is all coming down or
they're gonna elect a Democrat no or
whatever
your body then has some built-in
mechanisms to divert your attention from
that stuff that we can't control to this
and it's cool man body's just trying to
take care of you trying to love you
that's assuming again this isn't
biological in nature right but
sitting with somebody that can help you
slowly peel the thing apart let that
thing some of the tension of that energy
release
that's the path to Healing my friend
I'm so so grateful for you Sarah you're
a brave brave woman and you're an
incredible mom
starting today we're gonna start making
friends with Sarah we're gonna come to
love Sarah and Sarah's gonna become
somebody worth taking care of and loving
they're gonna be curious man why is my
body doing that
that's going to be where we start
getting well
thank you for the call we'll be right
back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor betterhelp hey
look there's a lot of things we don't
get to choose on this wild ride called
life right the neighbor's kid learning
to play Trombone weird things trending
on the tick tocks or whatever that is we
don't get to choose the weather but when
you realize how much you do have a
choice in it's so empowering check this
out you get to decide who you want to be
I get to ask myself the question who do
I want to be you get to choose who
speaks into your life and you get to
choose to pursue meaningful
relationships this is life-changing
stuff but I'll be honest it's not easy
these are new skills that we all have to
learn and therapy is a great place to
practice these new skills and that's why
I love better help better help is
Affordable online therapy that can match
you with a therapist quickly and it lets
you switch any time to make sure it's
the right fit and just like in-person
therapy it can help equip you with the
tools you need to work towards being who
you want to be because you don't just
have to let life happen to you you can
take it head on so visit betterhelp.com
deloney today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Joseph
in Pennsylvania what's up Joseph
hey Dr John how are you I'm all right my
brother what you doing
oh man am I nervous
dude I'm not that good at this man
there's nothing to be nervous about I
I'm way more nervous than you I promise
what's up yeah I I hear you hey um well
first I wanted to say thank you I've
been listening to you for over two years
and uh
thank you and to your whole team over
there at Ramsey um you gave me my wife
some tools to better our lives and y'all
are awesome dude thank you so so much
I'm appreciate you being in our gang for
a couple years man that's awesome
awesome just getting started dude I'm
grateful for you
quickly I think I need to provide a
little bit of uh context for our
situation for my question to actually
resonate sure if that's cool okay so I
have some notes here written down so uh
you got it
about three and a half years ago I made
the decision to pretty much change my
ways to kind of save my marriage and my
family
um I'm sorry I'm I'm really nervous
that's okay hey um do you mind if I stop
you and and clarify some things as
you're reading that
yeah sure okay
um what did you have to change
um so that's what I'm about to get into
so I was
um drinking more than I should had a
horrible tobacco habit was very
overweight okay
um miserable angry hard-headed
um all that I thought I knew everything
and then uh
what really changed when I started
listening and to your show um you say
you know you have to lay your your sword
and your shield down and uh so I did
um and then listening to the Ramsay show
as well I mean it I mean you guys like
forever changed my life man and and I'm
appreciative of that so I appreciate
that we do we just run it we just run
our outs man you actually did the work
you're the one that yeah I mean that's
that's a generation's worth of behaviors
you changed right
yes sir yeah now
um we were in our early 30s and
tobacco-free hardly ever drink I mean
wake up early gym six days a week read
books my marriage is I mean so much
better than I thought it ever could be
you lose weight
yeah man um 50 pounds oh man congrats
dude thank you thank you um we built a
net worth of about 425 000.
um so wow yeah dude yeah that's a total
slap it up flip it reversion dude how do
you how do you uh
how do you feel
well see that's kind of well part of my
reason for the call is man I feel great
like physically
um emotionally I feel
um you know since I I started to become
more vulnerable open-minded man I feel
so much better like just so much more
pure so much easy like easy life is
easier you know what I mean that that
word is that magic word of peace dude
like it's right it's just like that guy
cut you off in traffic and you're like
all right dude have a good day like you
know I mean like I don't feel like I
gotta kill him right that is exactly one
of my main things is is to like just let
him go man his you know what I mean his
day is his day and let him roll you know
what I mean you're gonna live ten years
longer just just on that alone awesome
okay so what where where are we here
what what what's the purpose of the call
yeah so yeah so I'm so proud of you dude
you're awesome yeah thank you so much
um yeah so I say all this stuff all this
good I mean it is good but I still
always felt this gap between my wife and
I
um that was bigger than any money saved
or weight loss you know what I mean so
we've become way more open with each
other over the past year and she has
told me
um just recently that uh this is hard um
uh when she was 15 she had consensual
sex with a 22 year old and no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
she did she did notes on my notes I have
consensual in quotes yes she did not she
was raped by an adult
exactly so whenever she told me this
um she's she started off by saying don't
look at me
um so she had shame all over her you
know what I mean and then
um I I explained I tried to explain to
her you know before she kept going that
that wasn't her fault you know what I
mean that that was an adult that took
advantage of a child right so good for
you um
yeah so but I still feel like symptoms
show up of that and like her daily life
and I guess my primary focus and my
primary question is like how to love her
the best I can and close this like final
Gap that I feel is still there that
derives from the crime the man committed
over 15 years ago yeah
um and she's never really had someone
where she can go to and just be her
right so like
um apparently her mom she couldn't go to
her mom you know and early in our
marriage which is why I led with all of
that was I wasn't that guy either
because I would have just gotten raged
out I would have just you know what I
mean what's his name well you know this
and that um
and so that's kind of where we're at now
and also I mean I need to forgive myself
for not being that guy
um at the beginning of our marriage you
know what I mean and I don't know how to
do that yeah
um there's several things here one a
couple of them are going to be hard to
hear and then a couple of them I think
you can take the bull by the horns okay
okay
um
you have
um you have done some
extraordinary life transformation
at some point along this journey and
that word is so like woo-woo and
spiritual like Gwyneth Paltrow and
that's I don't even like using it but it
is what it is like on this path that
you're on
you at some point will look up and
realize Oh I thought I was doing it for
this but I was actually doing it for
this
here's what I mean for most of us I
would say 99.9 of us we have to have a
Finish Line to get up
I'm not just gonna go train for seven
months to run on a Saturday morning at
five in the morning with ten thousand
strangers unless I know how far we're
running
and if they just said go you know what I
mean and like I don't like are we going
26 miles are we going forward like so
almost all of us have to get up and go
towards the finish line and that's what
you've done
I want to change my family tree I want
to be a better husband I just want to
feel good when I get up in the morning
for God's sake I want to laugh more than
I'm pissed off like but all of that was
towards
I want to accomplish this thing
okay and what you're finding out is
there's a limit to that because you can
only control you
and somebody else has to participate in
a marriage where both people are
constantly giving themselves up for the
other person
and so I tell you all that to tell you
you are on this path not to get a better
marriage you'll get a better marriage
along the way
you're not on this path just to lose
weight you will lose weight because
you're a guy who honors himself and his
family and his community by taking care
of his body
right so you're playing an infinite game
here and your kids are going to pick
that up and their kids are going to pick
that up and you'll have changed
generations of your family
and so
what you're finding out in real time is
you have quit one of the most difficult
habits on the planet which is nicotine
addiction you have quit one of the most
challenging
uh addictions in the planet which is
alcoholism because that's relational in
nature which meant you had to go get
connected with a real person instead of
pseudo connected with a bottle right you
have done one of the most impossible
things which is lose 50 pounds
right you've done all this stuff
and you can't control your wife and her
healing
and you have to sit in that
powerlessness and say okay the more I
try to solve this problem for her
the worse I'm going to make it because
what that 22 year old did was he took
her autonomy away
right he took that and does that make
sense yeah it does and just to be clear
she um she's realizing you know she's
she's in it um she wants to
um you know what I mean I just want to
know you know what can I do to help
guide her to help you know just be there
I did write her a letter the day after
she told me
um and she did keep it
um and she she she's all in she and she
listens to your show as well so she'll
be here on this call too it's awesome um
yeah and so she she is I just want to
know like is there you know should we go
to like is there marriage there is there
an exercise we could do well no there
will be there will be there will be
marriage counseling at at which here's
what she's got to learn to do number one
um the way she framed that interaction
you nailed it on the head she is her the
the blood that pulses through her veins
is shame
is disgust and it's discussed the way
she framed it I did this at 15. I chose
this at 15. no you didn't
all right right
um and so or yeah you chose that and you
were not in a position to make that
choice because you're a child right
um and so
the last thing we want to do is go in
and say okay let's do this thing so you
can fill in the blank or I've got this
exercise what she's gonna have to learn
over time is a this is not your fault
and not just learn that cognitively her
body has to come to understand that
she's also going to have to learn
um that
uh what's the right way like
that her she's gonna have to learn that
she has the power to make decisions and
choices for her life and learn how to
carry the responsibility for that
inappropriate way not and then like I'm
just carrying the whole thing myself
and so a great gift you can give her is
to ask her on a daily basis
how can I best love you today
and here's what she's gonna do she's
going to practice saying like nothing
I'm good nope give me one thing would
you honor me enough by giving me one way
I can love you today
I could do that and
um if she's okay with it and this isn't
the first for all um sexual assault rape
victims everybody's different right
um I've seen it very very powerful
healing is just can we hold hands
um and maybe touch bare feet like under
the covers can we just do it for five
minutes
and this is something we're gonna do
not so that you can get lucky or you
might right that might be something
you'll agree on but that's not the point
isn't like hey I know how to get this
ball rolling that's not it it's right I
want her to rest in you
exactly okay and it's gonna be something
she has to learn it's not learned like
cognitively she loves you and trust you
she wouldn't have married you she
wouldn't have been creating a life with
you her body has to feel that other men
are okay
and she may be there dude she may be
there but my guess is it's hard to be
sexually intimate with somebody who
thinks they're disgusting from the
inside out
yeah and that's the that's the one thing
like that I I'm trying to show her is
you know I think that she truly lacks
confidence and and honestly there's I
mean she's a beautiful she's amazing
she's smart you know I married way up
you know I mean most of us did man most
of us did hey but I want her I want you
to listen to the language I want to show
her this is not a theater performance
I'm going to be I'm going to be with her
okay okay so not how can I demonstrate
how beautiful you are how can I
demonstrate how much I love you that's a
show
okay
what do you need to feel safe today
and that might mean I'm gonna go get the
milk you all have kids
yeah too that might mean I'm doing
bedtime
okay that might mean I I call and get a
neighborhood knucklehead teenager to
come over and watch the kids because
we're gonna go for a walk
okay like what's give me one thing give
me two things
that we can do to love you and then I
can that I can love you and it's it's
not a matter of I'm showing you it's I'm
here and you can't get rid of me because
I'm I love you that much
um I want to make your life better
and that's a different thing does that
make sense it sounds like it's semantics
but it's not it's it's a it's another
level and then there will come there'll
come a season yeah man y'all will go to
a marriage counselor and it won't be a
million sessions probably but you'll
learn some things
and there'll be some hard moments that
you're gonna say God I wish you had told
me that 10 years ago and she's gonna say
I didn't have the language I didn't know
how and you're gonna find out that you
did some things that made her body feel
like back in and you're gonna feel all
weirded out and grossed and that's part
of this healing Journey that you're on
together
and the only person you control this
whole thing is you
yeah so no I that makes that makes
perfect sense I mean I completely
understand and that's something that you
know we're definitely going to look into
and you know it's actually I don't know
how to say this but like
almost like the we've done so much of
the hard work already alone with books
and you know
um listening to podcasts and just being
more open that now I feel like you know
if we were to go talk to someone
it would be almost just uh I don't want
to say quick and easy
um no no hey trust me it's not gonna be
quick and easy it's gonna be a mess but
here you were right you've learned all
of the lingo
and you've cognitively put all the stuff
in your head let me put it this way
you've watched a lot of basketball games
it's different when you get on the floor
right right and someone starts boxing
you out and they stuff your shot and
they just dribble right around you like
now you know how to play basketball
you've watched it a lot you even know
how the plays work now you gotta get on
the floor and start practicing and
you're gonna fall down you're gonna get
knocked over that's just gonna be part
of it
um but yeah that's you're way ahead of
the game you'll be able to sit down with
the therapist and I mean just reading
what you just wrote me
um makes me believe your wife won the
lottery with you
yeah I mean just god you're an amazing
guy dude you're an inspiration to all of
us
um and but hold on and
that's there's going to come a point
when there's a we if it's not there
already that's a weird challenge for her
I can never live up to the husband he is
and that feeds the of course not
you were X Y and Z back when you were
15. you've always been right and it
feeds an opposing narrative right so
you're not gonna
be more of a sucky husband to lower the
bar no but you're gonna be really
graceful to take a knee and say hey how
can I love you today
and she's going to practice saying what
she needs and then when you give it to
her not immediately going I don't
deserve this
but her going that's right because I'm
his wife I'm the I'm the woman he chose
because he loves me right
it's getting and it's gonna be this
practice this practice is practice but
dude yeah you gotta you got a hellacious
journey ahead of you and y'all are wait
on the road man that's awesome yeah I
got you I'm awesome and kudos to you
um
laughs
kudos to you for not immediately jumping
in and trying to solve this for her
good for you man because I think that's
most of our impulse is
sweet time to go to war
and we often
do the very thing that somebody who
assaulted our loved ones did would just
take away their autonomy we take away
their decision making we take away what
they want you don't get a vote I'm going
to war because this is about my ego and
me winning and my possession which is my
wife or my husband who
and you listened and you wrote a letter
that I'm assuming said
I'm here with you
the end of time
she will reread and reread and reread
that letter my brother
she's lucky to have you man stay on the
path stay on the path stay on the path
let me know how this this uh plays out
man I'd love to know how her counseling
goes and I'd love to walk with you guys
as y'all stay on this journey appreciate
you we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well-life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back dude one of my
favorite bands ever I don't have their
tattoo but man they're red
um
warrant especially off the dirty rotten
filthy stinky rich record Ah that's what
a great record that is
song is sometimes she cries and goes
like this
Mercy you don't think she's pretty no
more staring at the stars through her
back screen door she tries and tries to
make it all work out no matter what she
does she's left standing in the middle
of doubt in a lonely night and in the
pouring rain you can count on me and
sometimes she cries but she's alone at
night and sometimes she's weep when
she's feeling cold and weak sometimes
the pain it just tears her up inside
sometimes she cries
I wonder why hey go listen to that song
right now warrant sometimes she cries
it's a great dude man and tell the
people in your life that you love them
tell me that you love them I love you
guys we'll see you soon